chuckles well fire bad hit from three be
[ __ ] by smart look at is shaken
Russell will take and take from three
largest lead for Brooklyn
timeout Boston edom off one leg way
short
Russell the rebound and that goes back
to the thing stray beyond Graham does
to the regular yes-mo presented by
east-west bank your financial bridge
well this is where jared allen has an
advantage from big guys and of course
that past the Coons have been better
from D'Angelo Russell but look at him
search and look at him pushing and look
at Jeremy Roenick he was three steps
behind aron baynes when he started but
he's able to get up the floor out gets
it back seven to shoot
Russell step-back jumper is good
Allen had said said look the hardest
thing for me is learning how to be good
for 82 Russell hits the just learn
immediately points - Allen - thank you
for that script Russell already with ten
points in the quarter we be taking about
12
Russell Russell you know he's feeling
good you bet
[Applause]
time to dance fellas time a little bit
of flair screen turned over here comes
Harris Boston back Russell open he's
three it's good
time outsourced
[Music]
D'Angelo is gettin goin every third for
D'Angelo Russell through the lane cuts
it up it's all up and down right folks
and he was a kid